Okay, a ton of spoilers are here and
it's always exciting to sift through
these legends and see which ones are fun
to build. Do any of these stand out to
you? Okay, let's take a look through all
these one by one. Just kidding, it's
these idiots and it's not close.
Sacrifice a creature, draw equal to
power, this is ridiculous. Protects
itself, too. Hold your pipe weed, this
will be the greediest aristocrat stack
you've ever seen. Now, these guys are
different than Gitrog. Gitrog solves our
mana problems, the trolls don't. But
it's more easily repeatable, so we'll
have endless stream of cards if we can
keep feeding them big creatures. But big
creatures cost big mana, usually. If
only green and black had something like
sneak attack where I can just spend one
mana, cheat a fatty in, get some
triggers, sacrifice, draw, sneak, and
repeat. But in green and black, is there
a way for Golgari to give us a constant
stream of quality fatties for low mana
cost? If we can keep the cards flowing.
Hmm. Huh. Ho ho, would you look at that?
It's these again, please don't leave.
Okay, just imagine with me. Imagine this
game state. And now imagine how you can
lose from here.
Exactly, you can't. But the more astute
of you may have noticed something odd.
We have seven mana, how do we get all
these into play? Yeah, good question.
Well, you see, reanimate is just a
mostly better version of these undying
effects. So, what if alongside ramp, we
also include a reanimator package? That
seems reasonable. And it turns out a lot
of the cards we play are incidentally
very good at filling the graveyard, even
our commander. Okay, we have a deck. Fat
aristocrats. Screw sacking these tiny
little weenies for I draw a card, I
drain one life. Exile a thing, but only
four mana or lower. Instead of the
little dorcs, we've got these juicy boys
as fodders. The Armageddon,
the Terastodon.
Hold up. What sound is that? Is that Oh.
No way.
A sponsorship?
After a year of dedication and milking
my friends' deck ideas, are we going
full-time milking? Okay, not really.
Well, so here's how YouTube sponsorships
work when you're big and popular, brands
will approach you with offers, you
negotiate, and you take the best one
that you can morally justify. That
doesn't happen here. For us smaller
creators, we find a product we enjoy and
we go ask for an affiliate link. If
you're interested in some high-quality
accessories that really stand out, check
these out. But if not, just skip this
part. So, in my case, the brand I found
is Kakapopo. I've been using their deck
boxes for over a year now, before I even
started this channel, and they're really
high-quality. These ones still look
brand new. Now, some tiny marks on the
edges if I look hard enough, but I do
not handle these with care. So, yeah,
excellent quality. Also, these designs,
just see for yourself. They do stand
out. See something like this, I would
expect to pay something like $70, but
well, go to their site and see for
yourself. They have a lot of sweet
designs with excellent prices. And if
you're interested, use my code levels,
all caps,
for a discount on top of already
excellent prices. If you do, thank you.
It does give me motivation for all the
late night editing. But let's be honest,
I'll keep making content anyways, this
is just stuff I enjoy doing. So, don't
feel obligated or anything. But if you
do happen to need some sleeves or deck
boxes or dice, give them a shot. They
will not disappoint. All right, back to
our fatties. We do have some really
impactful stuff, a bit like the Gisa
deck. If we're building an engine to
reuse cast, ETB, or dying triggers over
and over again, we might as well go with
the biggest. Why blow up one thing when
I can do three? Also, just look at these
delicious bodies. We're drooling over
here. For more removals, we have
Sheoldred, but also this Shadow Grange
Archfiend. This card is ridiculous cuz
the deck has a lot of instant speed
discard outlets. It's like an
eight-power creature that reanimates
itself. And Massacre Wurm, this will
destroy decks that go wide. For
non-creatures, we are playing Bane of
Progress. We do have a few important
enchantments, but looping this will
straight-up hose certain decks. Just be
careful with this if your commander is
transformed. And if we're able to set up
the engine, we should prioritize
solidifying the advantage. And the best
way to do that is with over-the-top
ramp. Cultivator Colossus is ridiculous
with a big hand and Lumara or recover
whatever we end up discarding. It also
adds to the graveyard. So, Pollen-Blight
Druid is an all-star in the late game
and an excellent finisher. With just a
few triggers, we take over the game. And
Kokusho, oh, you cannot miss Kokusho.
We're also going a bit heavier with
tutors because we have to be restrained
when it comes to the number of fatties,
only a few for each kind of utility,
because we don't want to be too
top-heavy with the deck. The best one
here is Protean Hulk. Not having this
exile itself is such a design oversight,
and we are always here to capitalize.
Ghalta is one of the best reanimation
targets and it's also ridiculous late
game when we have 20 cards in hand. And
we have a really interesting finisher
here in Guff Triplets. We can just end
the game with this and our commander, we
don't even need anything else. We'll
draw into the undying effects. When
using the undying effects, though, be
careful to make sure you stack the
triggers properly. You let the Guff
Triplets come back first and then
resolve the one where you place the
counters. So, just one round, we end up
with five 6/6s. One more round and we
end up with four 12/12s and three 9/9s.
Now, please double-check my math, but if
it's correct, it's just ridiculous,
isn't it? A lethal board state out of
nowhere. Now, just like with any utility
package, it's fairly flexible. My group
is pretty creature-heavy, so I ended up
with more creature removals, but there
are tons of excellent options that you
can mix and match. For filling the
grave, we have all the best entomb
effects. These two are must-haves.
Imagine a Survival of the Fittest with
Archfiend in your deck. Also, these two
drop enchantments. For reanimation, it
has to be low cost and we have the best
ones. Also, these ones stable to a
creature. Oh, and of course, the most
exciting cards of the deck, these
undying effects. I get it, playing the
same common 15 times may get boring and
repetitive, but think about it. It's
It's an opportunity for us to explore
Magic's world-building, seeing how
people resist death in different worlds,
on different planes. It's a deep dive in
their customs and even values.
Fascinating. See, in Innistrad, it's
straight-up comfy, classic reanimation.
In Ravnica and D&D, you just pretend to
be dead. Yeah, remember when I was
decapitated? Just kidding, slight of
head. And in Tarkir and Amonkhet,
you just tough it out, I guess. Yeah,
you can just choose not to die. Liliana
hates this one trick. All right, now we
cannot depend entirely on reanimation.
We green, we got to ramp. And how hard I
choose to ramp in each deck depends
largely on how much card advantage our
commander can generate. And in this
case, we're playing, I guess, all of
them. Now, in this deck, we do have a
lot of creature synergy, so we're
including all the three-mana ones. The
Overlord also count. The Tortoise and
the Cavalier are less efficient, but
they do help fill the grave. Now, the
best quote-unquote ramp halves are
actually these ones over here. The Piper
and Olivia are excellent if they are
able to stick. And this one is a bit
strange, Heartless Summoning. This is a
crazy strong card, but it's awkward in
many decks. It also can be in this one.
I mean, it just kills the Piper. But
having this around for a few turns can
generate so much advantage. You have to
try it. For other utility pieces, we
have Greater Good. This is basically an
alternative version of our commander,
but arguably better. The Siphon can come
in clutch as a one-use. Scourge Familiar
is a bit expensive, but will win games
in the later phases. Torbran is another
alternative win condition, also a
decently large body as fodder. And
Demonic Tutor, yeah. For lands, we
prioritize sack outlets. We need them to
maximize the built-in protection in our
commander. This way, we're not only
dodging the destroy effects, but all
spot removals and creature board wipes.
And these ones, for their graveyard
synergies, the Kamigawa channel lands
are great because we have ways to
recover them after use. And these are
the MDFCs we choose. Nine basics is a
bit low, but if we get all nine onto the
battlefield, we're probably doing okay,
so not too worried about that. Now, the
deck is not super explosive. It does
require ramp or reanimation in the early
game to get going. And depending on the
game state, but usually we're not really
in a rush to cast our commander. I'd say
we want seven to eight mana before we
drop the trolls, because we want to make
sure that once we drop them, the value
train will be unstoppable. The deck is
not too difficult to play, it's a
typical graveyard/aristocrats
kind of strategy. It does search the
deck a lot, so knowing what to tutor for
in different situations can be helpful.
Now, the budget isn't exactly low, but
if you look at the expensive cards, I
don't think they're I mean, they're
powerful cards, but they're not
essential to our game plan. So, let's
say if we keep the budget under 200,
there will be a downgrade, but it's not
massive. I think it's doable. But even
if you cut all the game-changers, this
deck should be bracket three. I don't
think it's fair to put this in bracket
two.
So, yeah. Personally, I found that sets
are pretty hit or miss in terms of
interesting commanders. There's barely
anything I wanted to build from Turtles
and Spider-Man. Meanwhile, Avatar and
Strixhaven each had like half a dozen of
commanders I wanted to build. I have a
pretty good feeling about Hobbit, so
I'll be looking closely at the most
interesting legends from this set. So,
if you're interested, make sure to
subscribe and follow along. Also, do
check out Kakapopo, and make sure to use
my code levels, all caps, for a
discount. I'll see you.